Anna Faris steps out with rumored new
boyfriend Michael Barrett two months
after calling it quits from her husband
of eight years Chris Pratt the actress
has reportedly struck up a romance with
a cinematographer from her latest film
overboard according to multiple reports
the two had been spending a lot of time
together including a trip to the
carnival with ferris and Pratt's
five-year-old son Jack the blond beauty
kept it cool and casual for the outing
sporting a baseball cap Sony's a black
graphic tee shorts and sneakers
while Barrett sported a pair of brown
boots dark jeans a black t-shirt and a
matching hat an eyewitness told e.t
quote she was definitely happy she
seemed carefree and very relaxed it
seemed flirty for sure the two have been
spotted on various dinner dates around
Los Angeles and on Tuesday Faris was
seen dining at modo mio in Pacific
Palisades California though an
eyewitness wouldn't confirm who she was
with and while it appears the mom star
has moved on she still has nothing but
love for her estranged husband but he is
just a great man and he's a great actor
in a recent interview with People
magazine she explained quote there is
still so much laughter in our lives
together and he is so proud of me still
[Music]